Ah, three, two, one. Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad.
I'm Robert Krulwich today on
radio lab blame. All right.
So tell me your name again. Bianca.
Bianca, yeah. And I'm a quality name.
Thank you. Yeah. Okay. So this
is taped. It was sent to us, uh,
by a radio producer named Bianca Gaver
at the time she was in college just
starting out a bike and
across the country. Yeah.
We just got this grant to bicycle around
this summer and talk to you. Yeah,
it's called Davis projects
for peace. Oh Great.
And she was riding through this part of
Tennessee and ended up on this farm type
place where she met this guy, Hector.
My name is Hector black. I'm
86, almost 86 and a half.
When you get as old as I am,
you add the halfs again like
you did when you were three.
And Hector ended up telling Bianca
story that in many ways turns everything
we've learned in this hour on
its head. Um, so yeah, where's,
where would be the best
parts place to start? I mean,
I think the story starts when he decided
to move to Atlanta because that's where
Patricia was his daughter.
Okay. He had fought in the war,
a combat engineer, World War
II. I was not a good soldier.
Went to Harvard, got a degree,
met his wife Suzy, and then
I did join the civil
rights work in the 60s
I think when Hector heard about
the civil rights movement,
he actually packed up his bags,
moved to the neighborhood
where Martin Luther King Live,
rented a house and said,
what can I do to help?
I felt that I wouldn't really understand
what was going on unless I lived there.
And that's when he meets Patricia girl
in the neighborhood who came over all the
time, just like a lot of kids.
But she stuck around longer than,
than anyone else. And at 11 years old
she asked them, will you adopt me?
Why are you explaining? Did you
adopt Patricia? What happened?
How'd you sure she, her mom
was an alcoholic. Sometimes she
drank up the rent money and,
and the kids were out on the
street with their mom and dad. Mom,
there was no dad and uh, so we
took them in and she was very shy.
She had impetigo sores on her legs
in a nappy headed. Knew Your Mama,
never braided her hair. She was
just really a neglected child.
And so she just blossomed.
She got into reading, sewing,
painting. She made all her own clothes.
She's making bridal gowns as
a second source of income.
And then she went off to college.
She came back and started teaching kids
to read. She even took it a few kids,
just like he had done adopted a
couple of kids. Yeah, he was too.
She's a wonderful child.
So unfortunately the whole story changes
now in November of 2000 because that's
when Patricia,
okay, who was murdered?
Ivan Simpson is the name of
the man who killed her. Yeah.
He had broken into her house
looking for money and strangled her.
And later the autopsy showed he sexually
assaulted her too. At first, you know,
eight yellow kill the bastard
you guys saw, I saw it
kind of a monster. You
would do a thing like this
and he said for almost a year
he could not stop imagining
what he had done to her.
These visions that come at me
out of the blue just hit me.
Okay. Did you get,
he just said no control. It
was like he had control over me
pushing my face in the mud
after I haven't had confessed. And
this was right after the murder,
Hector said part of him did want
Ivan to get the death penalty,
but then this other part of him
was like, no, this is a test.
This was a test of his
principles of his beliefs.
And so he decided he would
not pursue the death penalty
it at the trial, um,
where he was sentenced,
he refused to look at Ivan.
Trisha's cousin got up first.
She was just in tears and just said how
much she hated him. I thought, oh Lord,
I hear I'm going to go say something
that's probably gonna hurt her feelings.
And when it came his turn,
I had a written statement
because of unsure how steady
my voice was going to be.
But I was saying how
much we love Patricia,
how much she meant to us and how
wounded we were by what had happened.
And I said, I don't know if I've
forgiven you. I haven't Simpson,
but I don't hate you. I hate with all
my soul what you did to my daughter.
And then you worked up the nerve to
turn around to face him to say the last
thing I had written that said,
I wish for all of us who had
been so wounded by this crime,
I wished that we might find God's
peace and I wish that also for you.
I even Simpson. And he
says when he looked up,
tears are streaming. Yeah,
there's cheeks and you know,
as the first time I looked into his
eyes and it was like a soul inhale
[inaudible]
I was just undescribable looking there
in the end. I haven't ended up
getting life in prison without parole.
What happens next was so surprising
and troubling to us frankly,
that we sent Bianca in our producer Andy
Mills back down to Tennessee to talk to
Hector again. Okay. So it's
the night after the trial.
Hector is laying in bed in the Mattel.
I couldn't sleep that night and he
kept thinking about that moment in the
courtroom. I'd never, I'd never had
it looked like that my whole life.
Never before or since over and over
and over and finally he just gets up.
He grabs a pen and paper and he starts
writing. Even Christopher Simpson,
I am writing
because I wanted you to know how I feel
after the court hearing Monday when I
turned around while I was reading
my statement and looked at you,
it was a very powerful moment for me
when you raised your tear stain face to
look at me. Ever since this happened,
I've been trying to find something good
in all the horror and pain I have tried
to be a better person
and then he writes this line maybe as
a way to push himself to be that better
person, but he writes, I forgive you
for what you did to our beloved daughter.
I don't know if this will be of any
comfort to you, but I wanted to tell you,
we will both have to live our lives
with the pain of this dude always there.
Patricia tried to make
the world a better place.
We should also try
[inaudible].
Did you think he would write you
back after that? I didn't know,
but about four weeks
later a letter shows up.
Yeah. This is it. Dear Mr
Hector, black and family,
I first want to say, God
bless you all in all things.
Second, I have to go
straight to the point.
I know God has forgiven
me. You have forgiven me,
but I can't forgive
myself. Not yet. Anyway.
I have so much anger at myself
right now. It's unbelievable.
This hardness I have against
mine, I will always be remorseful.
I used to hear God speak
to me all the time,
but I guess after what I did,
he took away his touch from me.
Right? No, I miss his voice.
I don't know that level
of love Ms Patricia had,
but if it's anything
like your example of it,
it is great. God comfort
you all in everything.
Few free to us. Me, anything you like.
If I can, I will try to answer it.
[inaudible]
dear Ivan, I was very
glad to have your letter.
I think it is important that we be as
honest as possible with one another and so
I have to tell you that it is
hard for me to write to you.
I wanted to know who he was. I would
really like to hear about your life,
about the people who loved you,
the people who hurt you because I wanted
to knew what had happened to him that
could make it possible for
me to do with the length is
[inaudible].
Ivan writes, Dear Hector, I was
adopted when I was two days old.
His mother was schizophrenia.
This is Simpson.
The one I call mom known took me in.
He was raised by his
grandmother's sister. She's 80 no,
I used to have to stay over there
with my natural mum while Marie,
my mom, no had to work. My
natural mom used to beat me.
Blurt out. I'm glad I got rid
of you when he was a little boy.
Maybe about 11 or so.
She took him and his younger brother and
his little sister to a swimming pool.
And you tried to drone all three.
One sister died. He stood there.
She drowned his little
sister in front of him,
just the most horrible
stuff. And so we asked him,
having heard all this from Ivan,
did he still blame Ivan or did he blame
his mom or society or something else?
Well, I, I do blame him. I
mean, he made the choices.
He made the choices.
There's no doubt about that.
But he says, knowing this
also made a Monterey Bat.
[inaudible]
dear Ivan, and tell Ivan about his
life. I grew up in New York City,
his family, two brothers. My
parents argued and fought a lot.
Basically his whole life story.
I've always loved working with plans and
after we left find the city and moved
back to the country and
I haven't wrote back
dear Hector, I was raised in the church,
but after starting drugs and alcohol,
I changed, responded dear Ivan,
I don't think God has
abandoned you dear Hector.
You're the only one writing
to me. No, we exchanged many,
many letters
and at some point in this back and forth,
this almost incomprehensible
thing happens. Do you Hector?
There are letters. First of
all, thank you for the pictures.
I never knew plum trees blossom.
Really just become [inaudible] casual.
My favorite bloom is the water lily
blossom. They'd talk about flowers.
It's beautiful things they'd read.
Dear Ivan, thanks for your letters.
I've been closing a story someone said
to be because I thought you would enjoy
it and sometimes you, Hector, just
the most mundane details of their day,
just sitting around this Saturday
evening been singing him is to myself
basically they became friends.
You knew Hector, you're right.
I do sense of bone developing.
Unusual because of the
circumstances. Nope.
At all. What I expected
to happen, you know,
and it's just so absolutely crazy.
You're actually,
oh gosh.
Yeah. We, we,
we started to send him Christmas packages
and we see this box on the floor and
then I think to myself, you crazy old man,
you're Sydney Christmas packages for
the man who murdered your daughter.
What the Hell is [inaudible] with
you? So Cross
so totally out of
orbit or something and I guess that
was because people don't do that.
Maybe I'm trying to exact meaning from it.
I don't know because I
struggled so hard with y
y
no.
Eventually after years of writing letters,
Hector decided to ask that why question
[inaudible]
in its most essential form.
What happened that night?
This one? This one.
I just want you to know if you don't
want to read this. Oh yeah, we don't.
We don't want to make you read this. If
you, if you're not, you're not ready.
I don't think it's, this might
be a good time to say that.
This next part is disturbing. If you
have kids or you're just not in the mood,
now's a good time to duck
out for a few minutes.
Dear Hector, I wasn't
going to tell you. Oh,
what happened until you asked.
I'm also glad you're
relieving me of details. Also.
God bless you.
I went into the house around 7:30 PM
I'm used to breaking into place in the
past, so I figured the
house was total dark,
so I broke out a whole
window and climbed in.
I took the VCR and TV and clock.
I figured that was enough.
Went and gut $80 worth of
drugs. I'm a heavy users,
so it went in about one hour.
So he made his way back to Trisha's house.
It was still dark. So I went back in.
He found his way into the bedroom. I
saw a computer in Stereo,
so I said I take it and that
should last for the night.
But I got trapped when I saw a car,
so I hid until I could get
back out the way I came.
So I saw a lady walk to the room.
I tried to be quiet so I could escape.
When she opened the door to a closet,
I was hiding. As she
stepped back, she fell.
I told her I was going to tie her up
so it would have time to get away.
She said, okay sir.
Her glasses fell off and at no time she
saw my face so I told her I was going to
take the car so I could load it up.
She gave me the keys so I told her
after I found out her name, I said,
Patricia,
I know you're scared but I will be
out of here in about 15 minutes.
Then she said, you should get
help with your drug problem.
I told her I tried in the past
but I restarted or yeah, that's,
that's Trish.
She had no compunctions about telling
people off when they were in the room and
then I, I'm sorry for this,
I'm going to leave your car in the
shopping center up the street next to the
Chinese restaurant because all I need
the car for was to transport the items I
had
and even though Trish was
tied up around her hands,
she went into the kitchen and warmed
up some chicken and rolls for Ivan.
Then I said, I'm sorry, and I left again.
I got rid of the things,
got about $200 well a hundred
dollars drugs and $100 cash.
Then I said, well, I just parked
the car at the end of the driveway.
Then I couldn't wait. I pulled over
and smoked some of the crack cocaine
and at this point he's really high and
he explained that when he gets this high,
he's sometimes here's a male voice in
his head and as he was walking away,
the voice said to him,
he said, well, go get you some sex.
I told him, leave me alone, but next thing
I know I'm walking back to her house.
No police had come.
He burst through the door, ran to
where Patricia was tied up and said,
did you have any money? Kind of
wish. She said, look in my purse,
and then Ivan said that the voice in his
head became his own voice and he said
to her, I want some six
[inaudible].
She said, sir, you've been
so nice. Why don't do that?
Yeah.
You said only way you going
to do this if I'm dead.
Okay then and it happened.
He strangled her, sexually
assaulted her, then he ran away.
Sure. Around 2:00 AM I ran out of drugs.
You said that after he
finished getting high,
he started to wonder if
he had dreamt it all up.
So he made one last trip
back to Patricia's house.
So I looked up at the house. No
police and gate's still open.
So now have peeps through the
door. She was still laying there.
So I said Patricia, Patricia,
and then the voice in his head told
him to go back in one more time.
He sexually assaulted her.
I couldn't believe what happened.
So went to my mom has adopted
mother and I said, Mama,
it's something wrong. Moma,
something wrong. She said, child,
tell me what you're talking
about. I couldn't tell her
[inaudible]
I was really hoping they would kill me
in the electric chair because I could,
I shouldn't be able to live with
myself and God after what I had done.
I just don't know why I had to do it.
Was it because of the
items and the money? No.
Getting caught later on in life.
No control or power? No car?
No. Because she saw my face. No,
she didn't see me at no time
fingerprints left on something.
No, I just don't understand why I did it.
[inaudible]
well, I feel the pressure has left me
for telling you first what happened.
My mom doesn't even know.
I've been keeping all this
inside and it hurts. So
I'm truly sorrowful for what happened.
May God bless you all sincerely. Ivan
does it, did it help?
But any way to know?
Yes,
because I mean that
sounded exactly like Trish,
but she was, was a really the fearless,
I mean a machine, Mr Burrito, I
can't imagine what a horrible,
Oh God. And his chest
amazed that she could be so strong
just to be raised because when you love
somebody very much, you want to know
about their last hours and
ah,
he, he just, he just wrote
it in a way that I found
very kind.
I mean if you go grind is a
weird word to put there, but
[inaudible]
but that's the word he chose.
Hello
kind
[inaudible]
after that letter, they still
right? Yeah, they still write,
they've been writing for 10 years now and
Hector has folders and stacks of these
papers in his basement. So only room
in his house that he keeps locked.
[inaudible]
producer Bianca gave her thanks
also to our own Andy Mills.
Thanks to you for listening.